one of the interesting things about
healthcare today is the data is becoming
unsilent and increasingly accessible so
for example I'm wearing right now a
little patch my company called vital
connect underneath my shirt it's talking
to my smartphone live and I can look at
my dashboard of my data for my full-on
EKG which will show up right here and it
can track the trends and hopefully my
EKG looks like it's okay if there are
any cardiologists out there I can also
see data about my steps my stress level
my position you know if I fall down and
I don't get back up the the the system
can tell that and this is really you
know an intensive care unit like type
level data in a what will be you know
less than $5 day disposable patch which
can be useful if you're training for a
marathon if you're in a hospital and
you're not on a monitored bed if you're
home with a disease like heart failure
that's a lot of data we're need to learn
to sift through it and pull out the
signals cuz no physician or nurse is
gonna want to be liable for watching
your live streaming EKG but is an
immense amount of power and data and
we're in this era now of creating
digital health exhausts you know whether
it's my smart watch this patch my phone
it can tell a lot about me my behaviors
if for example you have a patient who's
got bipolar disorder you can tell from
their phone whether they're depressed or
they're manic that can play a role in
smart disease disease management we can
take technologies like 3d printing and
tune home based prosthetics we can print
prosthetic hands for folks and legs in
the developing world
here's mini-me in my pocket it's a 3d
printed version of me that might be
interesting if I need to make a
prosthetic for someone who's lost part
of their face or I was at MIT Media Lab
last week and met a young grad student
who diagnoses ain't own brain cancer
written up in the New York Times and
used 3d printing to print a version of
his tumor he said hey you want a printer
you want to print on my brain tumor
this helped his surgeons do a better job
of finding it and removing it and he was
proactive he noticed some neurologic
symptoms and pushed for his own repeat
MRI that helped him get diagnosed
earlier I have in my pocket a new
commercialized version of a brain
computer interface from a company called
interacts and this is the muse
you can wear this headset and kind of
use this for a path I'd mindfulness and
meditation and I might use this to
prescribe to a patient who has anxiety
instead of giving them a drug I give
them a headset of course they can do
meditation the old-fashioned way but
this enables you to quantify it and have
a bit of a feedback loop so the ability
to sort of quantify our own minds with
brain computer interface like this can
be used to treat everything from PTSD to
ADHD we're gonna see use of video games
to improve cognition or to treat disease
we're seeing fancy brain computer
interfaces from my alma mater Brown
Brown University to enable someone who's
quadriplegic just by thinking to move a
robotic limb and those were getting
smaller and more integrated and so the
disabled in the future may just think
move my arm and I'll be rewired back to
their own arm even if they have a spinal
cord injury so lots of ways to take you
know sometimes consumer devices
crowdsource new apps and platforms on
these that will change you know
neuroscience psychiatry and when we can
pull this data together when we come
become participatory in healthcare we
can move to an era kind of like with
Google Maps you donate some data when
you use Waze in Google Maps your privacy
your speed your location but exchange
you can build a map of your of the
streets and other traffic so you get
some information back I think we can
have that same sensibility and
healthcare whether it's sharing your
brainwaves
your genomics your wearable data while
maintaining privacy and opt-in abilities
you know using that information can give
us better public health you know very
early signals if it's Ebola coming or
the common flu or can enable patient
groups to crowdsource better cures for
Crohn's disease for example this is new
world of the microbiome we have ten
thousand times ten ten times more
bacterial cells in turn on arm in and on
our bodies and our own human cells we're
learning that the microbiome plays a
role and everything from obesity to
inflammatory bowel disease like Crohn's
disease maybe even some psychiatric
disorders and we're just starting to be
in this era of fecal transplants and you
can imagine in 5-10 years you're gonna
get a tune cocktail of a probiotic
that's going to reboot your GI system to
help treat diseases or prevent them so a
lot of these tools are going to enable
the clinician you're gonna be going to
your corner you know pharmacy in many
cases to get medical care or
telemedicine
it's gonna enable you as an individual
to own your own health information
there's already thousands of apps out
there some are better than others but
you can use those as tools to stay
engaged in taking your vitamin your
aspirin or being on top of a much more
complex regimen and the challenge for
all of us is to integrate these in the
in the culture of health and medicine
you have the best technology but unless
your clinician uses it and gets paid for
it in some cases it may never be adapted
the payers of the world need to start
looking at how some of these can provide
better outcomes at lower cost and even
before they're fda-approved bringing
these to market and I think we're seeing
many smart pharma companies payers
physician groups think about how they
layer these in to be the disruptor and
not to disrupt deep